num place aux grands débats on va
s'arrêter ce soir sur les éoliennes qui
déchaîne les passions surtout depuis le
coup de gueule de stéphane bern
elles sont un déni de démocratie elles
n'ont rien d'écologique nous dit-il un
discours qui vient semer un peu le
trouble alors que l'exécutif a bien
l'intention de les développer sur tout
le territoire alors éoliennes vraiment
écologique ou pour ouvrir le débat avec
nos invités dans un instant d'abord les
points de vue exprimés ces dernières
heures sur ce sujet avec samia de chair
elles font désormais partie de notre
paysage
la france compte aujourd'hui un peu plus
de 8000 éoliennes c'est déjà beaucoup
trop pour les opposants à ce type
d'énergie il lance une offensive
médiatique dernière attaque en date la
tribune de l'animateur stéphane bern
il est grand temps de dénoncer cette
supercherie l'énergie éolienne n'est en
rien écologiques et renouvelables elles
polluent gravement la nature et détruit
le patrimoine naturel et bâti de la
france que les éoliennes des figures les
éoliennes fonctionnent seulement 25% du
temps et nécessite l'aide de centrales à
charbon qui rouvre notamment en
allemagne
quelle belle victoire très relayée le
texte a été salué par une partie de la
droite et surtout par l'extrême droite
le rassemblement national en a fait un
thème central de sa campagne aux
élections régionales grâce au nucléaire
nous disposons déjà d'une économie
décarbonée dans sa majorité
pourquoi détruire nos paysages et
provoqué de multiples nuisances en
semant partout des champs d'éoliennes un
faux débat dénoncent les écologistes
pour qui lés au lien est au contraire
bien plus propre que le nucléaire
en même temps que ce monde cette
critique qui se rencontrent les
éoliennes montre vraiment un lobbying
forcené pour le nucléaire français est
ce qu'on s'est posé la question des
millions des 6 millions de mètres cubes
qu'il va falloir pour enfouir les
déchets nucléaires est ce qu'on s'est
posé la question sur le recyclage des
déchets nucléaires
non on se pose pas ces questions là le
gouvernement qui vise les 23 % d'énergie
éolienne d'ici 2030 lance une contre
offensive médiatique pour démonter un
par un les arguments des opposants
les éoliennes ne serait pas recyclables
c'est faux recycler les éoliennes est
aujourd'hui une obligation réglementaire
90 % de la masse des éoliennes doivent
être démantelées fondation incluse puis
recyclés et
utilisez autres fake news dénoncé par
l'exécutif les éoliennes ne produisent
pas en permanence et nous obligerait à
recourir aux centrales à charbon faux
assure le gouvernement
c'est quand le parc nucléaire ne suffit
plus qu'il faut combler par des énergies
fossiles est avec nous pour le grand
débat ce soir patrick chaize bienvenue
vous êtes sénateur l air de lin vice
président de la commission des affaires
économiques et membre du groupe d'études
énergie au sénat
antonio duarte bienvenue à vous
également vous êtes secrétaire général
adjoint de l'ugtt cee union des
centristes des écologistes fondateur de
planet verte c'est un club de réflexion
sur la transition écologique et la
biodiversité avec nous également à
distance jean louis dutrey bienvenue
vous êtes président de la fédération
environnement durable votre fédération
sort justement aujourd'hui un film
documentaire intitulé éoliennes du rêve
ou réalité il est diffusé sur youtube il
dénonce les limites écologiques et
énergétiques de l'éolien et lucile
schmitt est également avec nos bienvenue
vous est cofondatrice et vice présidente
du think tank la fabrique de l'écologie
précise que vous êtes membre d'europe
écologie les verts
le sujet revient donc sur la table avec
cette tribune choc de stéphane bern ces
mots peuvent un peu surprendre à madame
pompili les éoliennes sont une négation
de l'écologie antonio duarte les
éoliennes sont une négation de
l'écologie non je crois pas je comprends
le point de vue de stéphane bern qui est
tout à fait respectable qui a un
défenseur du patrimoine français mais le
patrimoine de paysages de nos
territoires a évolué au fil des siècles
par l'impact du paysage non mais ça ça
clairement un impact paysager faut en
parler il n'y a pas de ya pas de sujet
tabou aujourd'hui à que 20% du
territoire français qui peut accueillir
des éoliennes
donc on parle d'une toute petite
minorité du paysage et avec des
avantages qui dépasse très largement les
léger inconvénient qui peuvent avoir et
il faut en débattre sans difficultés
mais je crois qu'il faut raison garder
aujourd'hui
la tendance est effectivement développer
les énergies renouvelables dont l'éolien
terrestre mais aussi l'éolien maritime
face à la baisse de nucléaire dans le
mix énergétique français est dans cela
effectivement le photovoltaïque l'éolien
a toute sa place dans le mix français et
je salue la ministre de l'ecologie qui
effectivement j'ai continué à pousser
l'énergie éolienne ce qui est nécessaire
pour doubler aujourd'hui la production
en france parce qu'on a cinq fois moins
d eau genk en allemagne trois fois moins
qu'au danemark
donc on a beaucoup de retard en la
matière j'insiste quand même un peu
stéphane bern ne parle pas du tout que
du paysage loin de là il en a remis une
couche d'ailleurs auprès de notre
journaliste hier qu'il a eue en ligne
une journaliste antoine comté nous dit
les éoliennes ce sont des matériaux
construit en chine jusqu'à 500 mètres
cubes de béton coulés par socle qu'on ne
pourra jamais enlever des cimetières de
pâles entier car on ne peut pas les
recycler des oiseaux migrateurs
complètement déboussolés c'est ça
l'énergie verte dont on nous parle
patrick chaize je me mets à la place des
téléspectateurs et moi même je ne
connais pas grand chose au sujet ça
interroge quand même on se pose vraiment
la question ces défaites nous ça non je
ne pense pas que ça soit défectueuse je
pense qu'effectivement ça interroge et
le drame de l'éolien comme peut-être des
énergies renouvelables dans leur
ensemble c'est que la démarche a été une
démarche un peu dogmatique
on a oublié peut-être de faire le bilan
ou en tout cas de mesurer l'impact
environnemental de ces énergies et je
peux comprendre qu'on peut vraiment le
regretter aujourd'hui n'est pas trop
tard mais il est urgent il serait urgent
aujourd'hui de faire le bilan
environnemental devient parce que tout
ce qui est dit était vrai avec donc des
arguments qui peuvent venir minimiser
ces choses là et j'entends quand vous
dites il ya un impact faible c'est 20 %
du territoire etc
on peut effectivement raconter
l'histoire avec ce genre de propos mais
mais globalement aujourd'hui je pense
que malheureusement on est sur des
propos qui engage ceux qui les dénoncent
sans forcément avoir eu une étude ou des
études
rationnelle et donc qu'ils puissent nous
donner vraiment une base
lucile schmid quand vous entendez
stéphane bern enfin c'est lui qui a
envahi dire démocratiser le sujet mais
ce qu'il dit est faux alors on ne vous
entend pas dû c'est chouette
oui voilà vous entends alesi par donc je
vous en prie je vous laisse répondre là
vous m'entendez on vous entend c'est
l'article d'accord mais est ce que j'ai
ce que je disais c'est une motion prend
tout ce qu'il dit pas cette terre
naturelle après se passe en ce qui
concerne l'éolien c'est qu'on a du mal à
associer par la préservation de la
nature et la transformation
technologique est liée au fait de mon
mieux maîtriser notre consommation
énergétique
moi je trouve que l'exemple d'associer
le nucléaire et les ou bien un mauvais
exemple
ce qui est important c'est d'avoir
conscience qu'il faut faire monter en
puissance l'électricité si nous voulons
sortir les énergies fossiles
c'est à dire qu'il faut davantage de
transport électrique on voit le
développement de l'électrique
il faut évidemment maîtriser davantage
dans importations de pétrole de gaz etc
et donc la montée en puissance de
l'électricité
c'est un mix énergétique différent dans
lequel l'éolien à sa perte
la deuxième chose les tenir c'est qu'il
me semble qu'on peut plus faire de
l'aménagement de voir on nous faisait
peut-être dans les années 70 lorsqu'il
n'y avait encore bon autoroutes
lorsque justement on a consommé les
centres nucléaires aujourd'hui nous
avons d'électricité en abondance et
quelque part le fait de montrer comment
on peu différemment l'électricité ça
doit s'expliquer aux citoyens on n'a
plus vraiment strictement réservé aux
experts aux techniciens et quelques pas
de relève d'une forme de contestation
démocratique il faut associer les
citoyens à sept questions
d'acceptabilité de l'éolien alors en ce
sens un coup de gueule de stéphane bern
les arguments je ne reconnais pas mais
le fait qu'il faut désormais envisager
la question d'une aile avec départ
démocratique écouter ce que disent les
riverains ce que disent ceux qui
habitent le territoire et prendre en
considération pro
une partie dans un pub vante un point
essentiel alors jean louis butré on
parlera de l'acceptabilité dans une
minute mais est ce que oui ou non en
gros la question c'est est-ce que les
éoliennes sont vraiment écologique non
seulement ce compte l'incroyable du
reste je vous invite tous à regarder ce
film il ya des experts très connu qui
donc ont parlé dans ce film est
franchement les dénonce le point de vue
écologique en priorité alors moi ce qui
me frappe dans vos propos tu c'est
d'abord j'ai l'impression d'un discours
parisien actuellement de jeu de l'éolien
20% du territoire
moi ce que ce que je vis et je suis
bénévole
il faut savoir que tous tous les gens
lesquels on lutte en général ce sont des
gens qui ont un intérêt à ce que je vois
c'est que la france rurale se révoltent
et se révoltent pourquoi pourquoi 1700
associations pourquoi tous les jours
vous avez dans les journaux locaux
régionaux telle personne tel groupe de
personnes ne veulent pas d'éoliennes et
c'est pourquoi tous les jours il ya des
associations qui se créent alors on peut
dire tout ce qu'on veut quand la france
9 de quelque chose elle résiste est
actuellement quand on voit monter cette
cette résistance baissé de puissance
incroyable que actuellement pas riche
mais essaie de faire passer le message à
maquereau aujourd'hui on va vers une
catastrophe je pense démocratique et
cette catastrophe évoquera tique quand
je vois que des récupérations comme le
front national
ces problèmes ce sont des braves ruraux
à qui on met des machines en de vente de
180 mètres 200 mètres de haut qui
entendent des parisiens il ya 20% du
territoire sépare très grave non y
réaliser c'est ça appuie alors y'a quand
même un autre problème dont on veut pas
parler que pour cacher tout ça c'est est
ce que c'est
escaudain mythique et je vous invite à
regarder ce document donc qui est un
film quand mais je vous pose est est-ce
que
écologique et économique oui absolument
non non les coudes quand on parle du
recyclage alors ça me fait rire quand on
voit des robes peut-être on arrivera les
recycler j'entends des gens qui disent
on va les mettre dans cimenteries les
pales il faut voir ce que c'est qu'ils
viennent c'est une pâle qui fait 13
tonnes quand on met dix milles sur la
france n est pas les unes derrière les
autres jusqu'à moscou
il valait brûlés dans des cimenteries
non mais on se paye de la tête des gens
ça quand on parle quand on parle de
mettre des éoliennes en offshore je
parle pas de l'offshore met donc la baie
de saint brieuc et j'entends des
associations le lv écologique 10h benon
c'est pas grave
broc parkes et c'est dans une lettre à
sensible pour les oiseaux pour les fonds
marins on va tester si pour voir ce que
c'était
des barges qui fore 1 qui met des pieux
dans le fond d'une baie lanta nous
expliquait d'écologie mais je peindrai
sa élevé nous n'avons rien contre partie
il ya dedans des dvd des choses
remarquables qu'ils font pour un seul
coup se sont ils mis à te plaît tu mens
promoteur d'une d'une technologie qui
est en train de détruire et paf tu
rencontres élargies aux premières loges
pour faire circuler la parole vous avez
donc tenu à parler vous avez raison de
l'acceptabilité de la population c'est
aussi ce que dit effectivement stéphane
bern ce que les bobos parisiens ne voit
pas c'est qu'une colère est en train de
monter en france et ça le gouvernement
va le payer politiquement cette colère
est terrible dit-il et c'est pour moi
une forme de mobilisation très semblable
à celle des gilet jaune
et effectivement cette colère est
notamment exprimé par les marins
pêcheurs de saint brieuc alors puisqu'on
en a parlé on va les entendre parler
effectivement de parcs éoliens offshore
parce que ce projet n'a pas n'a pas lieu
d'être
on a town pour notre
l'avenir de notre métier voilà c'est pas
c'est pas ces paquets demande des études
on leur donne plein de choses et ils ont
apporté aucune réponse à nos questions
1 ce projet il n'est pas écologique pour
la simple et bonne raison que
aujourd'hui l'éolien oui pourquoi pas
mais pas au détriment de nos ressources
en baie de saint brieuc pas au détriment
de nos coquilles saint jacques qui font
vivre toute une filière pas au détriment
de l'ensemble de la faune et la flore
c'est en baie de saint brieuc
on s'est donné trop de mal pour avoir
des gisements perrin pour tout détruire
aujourd'hui sous couvert de pseudos
écologie antonio duarte beaucoup
d'accusations 1 visant les éoliennes les
parcs éoliens et notamment offshore de
la part de ces marins je crois qu'il ya
beaucoup de fausses informations qui
sont répandues y compris par notre ami
stéphane bern répondre d'abord sur
l'éolien terrestre puis sur le minime
sur le terrestre
les éoliennes ne produisent les maîtres
que 20 grammes de co2 contre 40 à 60
pour les autres énergies donc c'est deux
fois moins nuisible pour l'environnement
premièrement deuxièmement sur le coup
aujourd'hui l'énergie nucléaire qui
représente faut le rappeler pour les
citoyens 75 % de l'énergie consommée en
france et qui va dans la part va être
réduite à 50% coûtant entre eux 60 80
euros le kilowatt heure mais ça va
passer à 120 euros avec le p r de
flamanville donc c'est deux fois plus
cher deux à trois fois plus cher que
l'éolien terrestre est quatre fois plus
cher que l'éolien maritime qui est une
des énergies les moins chers de sur les
énergies renouvelables donc l'éolien
c'est moins cher pour le consommateur ça
rapporte de l'argent
c'est cette fois plus de taxes par par
l'énergie par rapport au nucléaire pour
les collectivités locales mécontentement
là qui est en train d'émerger guerre
injustifiée selon vous je dis pas ça
mais faut faut rationaliser le débat
accord et regarder les choses de
manières objectif quand on dit on peut
pas recycler une lienz et faune a déjà
démantelé le premier parc dans les
pyrénées atlantiques
qui pourra voir des éoliennes plus
performante et 90% sont recyclables et
on va bientôt passer à 95% sur le bruit
aujourd'hui une éolienne ça fait pas
plus de bruit qu'un ventilateur de salle
de bain entre 30 et 60 db pour parler
couramment ça fait moins de bruit qu'une
voiture ou un klaxon et en général les
éoliennes obligatoirement sur la 300
mètres des premières habitations et
souvent beaucoup plus donc aujourd'hui
une dramatisation du débat c'est ce que
vous ayez quelques dire qu'il ya
quelques aficionados du patrimoine qui
cible aujourd'hui les éoliennes mais un
ski est ce qu'ils ciblent tous les
panneaux publicitaires qui sont dans les
entrées de ville les panneaux mcdonald's
ce qui gâche notre paysage s qui cible
les ya trois fois plus de moulins à vent
en france que d'éoliennes il ya cinq
fois plus de château d'eau nommé il ya
il ya trente cinq mille château d'eau
personne n'en parle
est-ce qu'ils sont très beau
esthétiquement pas toujours bon après
sur la question esthétique moi je suis
architecte urbaniste je suis aussi
sensible que je suis né à versailles
dans une ville classée monument
historique je suis extrêmement soucieux
de leur intégration dans le paysage et
je crois que le design d'éoliennes s'est
beaucoup améliorée mais moi je serais
partisan pour lance un concours pour les
designers des artistes contemporains
pour avoir un nouveau paysage artistique
dans nos campagnes et et que ça devienne
agréable après forcément les éoliennes
il y avait il y avait il y avait cent
mille moulin à vent au dix neuvième
siècle
donc ça a disparu en a cinq fois moins
aujourd'hui les éoliennes dans 50 ans il
y en aura beaucoup moins parce que ras
d'autres énergies renouvelables qui
seront beaucoup plus performante moins
cher donc ses enchaînements histoire
c'est transitoire que c'est extrêmement
limité sur notre territoire et les
nuisances objectivement sont extrêmement
faibles et personne ne parle des
avantages avantages monétaires pour le
citoyen impôts locaux pour les pour les
mères 10000 euros pour pour un méga
watts
donc c'est je sais bien que stéphane
bern préfèrent payer ses impôts mais
tout le monde n'a pas les moyens
aujourd'hui de financer les les 36000
communes de france qui ont des finances
locales très étriqué et donc et en plus
évidemment c'est écologique
donc ça va dans le sens
gérer des accords de paris après il faut
pas faire tout en éolien alors on va
laisser la parole à patrick saison va
laisser vous répondre oui alors sur
cette présentation c'est à dire c'est
vraiment là aussi la caricature de débat
qu'on peut avoir sur les éoliennes en de
graham temps de silence à sauf que une
éolienne
elle peut pas fonctionner tout seul
parce qu'une éolienne par définition
c'est une énergie intermittente se dire
que à côté de l'éolienne
il faut qu'on ait un moyen de faire en
sorte qu' on puisse continuer à produire
de l'énergie
ça peut être soit les centrales
thermiques soit de l'énergie nucléaire
souhaite donc ça c'est un chien un
premier point qu'il faut rencontre et
quand on parle de la production donc du
kilowatt éolien il faut prendre en
compte l'ensemble de la chaîne et c'est
pour ça que je dis qu'il manque
aujourd'hui leurs études
une étude vraiment sérieuse sur l'impact
environnemental de l'éolien dans son
ensemble sur le niveau d'acceptabilité
je voudrais vous acceptez cette crèche
franchement je je on ressent
effectivement ce rejet
moi j'étais assez stupéfait lors de
rencontres avec les élus locaux qui
quand ils ont établi leur pc à autun les
plans climats donc énergie territoriaux
air énergie territoriaux dans les
bureaux d'études qui les accompagne tout
le monde a mis un parc éolien dents pour
pouvoir répondre aux objectifs
et maintenant arrive l'heure où ils sont
sollicités pour faire personne n'en veut
personne ne veut ni dans les élus ni
dans la population
donc oui il ya un problème de de
pédagogie d'acceptation parce que
justement on n'a pas tout dit et
évidemment moi je veux dire qu'on fasse
un parc éolien à versailles ça me gêne
pas non hors de question mais mais nos
questions c'est pas parce que paix parce
que je suis un adversaire mais parce que
mais vous avez les merci de cette
réponse vous êtes en milieu urbain
exactement ce que c'est
évidemment c'est exactement je veux
l'entendre mais est donc donc
globalement ça veut bien dire que
globalement en théorie on peut en parler
on peut y trouver plein avantage quand
on rentre dans la pratique ces
problématiques
et puis il ya quand même des sujets qui
sont plus politique plus profond c'est
des sujets de dépendances
parce que l'éolienne dans sa fabrication
notamment les éoliennes offshore donc on
dans leur construction des métaux rares
une tonne de métaux rares par éolienne
offshore cm on va les chercher en chine
donc on se crée une dépendance
énergétique en fait quelques passes que
le nucléaire n'a pas su arrêter de
matériaux rares pilotes
il en a dérangé pas défendu lui clair là
je suis on en parle lui de l'éolien et
je suis en train de dire que l'éolien ne
doit pas être béat devant et de rien et
c'est pas la solution à tout et c'est
pas quelque chose qui répond à toutes
les problématiques écologiques ce n'est
pas vrai on a été donné la parole à
lucile schmid pour vous répondre
[Musique]
pas très bien je sais pas comment voilà
ça y est mieux dans des bars et bars
j'écoutais disait en des pêcheurs sur
les coquilles saint jacques
on voyait bien son l'écologie non
écoutez je suis désolé malheureusement
là on a vraiment un petit souci ça ne
fonctionne pas peut-être jean louis
butré je vous laisse la parole pour
réagir et ce côté moi j'ai entendu une
sorte de l'inexactitude quand on tente
l'économie dfe relief c'est plus c'est
moins cher point de vue électricité non
c'est une électricité subventionné
depuis des années et actuellement les
françaises et les français qui payent
ils ont qu'à regarder leurs factures
d'électricité
quelle nouvelle hausse pour l'année
prochaine pourquoi parce qu'on
subventionne des animatiques ne sont pas
rentables qui sont comment d'allier
intermittente
il ya un deuxième phénomène c'est que
tout mais j'ai odienne de viette ne sont
à sont pas fabriqués en france et
viennent d'allemagne et du danemark
alors je peux vous dire que quand on
leur ouvre un marché de 10 mille
machines c'est à dire des multiples et
30 ou 40 4 millions d'euros pièce c30 à
4,11 milliards d'euros ton qui se
jettent sur la fin la france et vous
avez des ordres de prospecteurs on a
lâché qui créent des sociétés sans
capital uniquement pour gagner de
l'argent et c'est la même chose que je
demande
et ça c'est vraiment officiellement
traite ces sociétés ne publient pas
leurs bilans c'est à dire qu'on ne peut
pas savoir d'où vient l'argent éolien et
où va l'argent via un pour des questions
soit disant 2 de secret donc ce n'est
pas normal
actuellement vous allez 1400 parcs
éoliens on ne sait pas d'où vient
l'argent et où va l'argent c'est l'écran
ce qui paye et on pêche et des fraudes
alors je vous en signale une parce qu'on
a déposé plainte actuellement quel âge
qu'on appelle la tour ou d'orages décima
il ya une règle qui dit les jeunes les
parcs éoliens qui conclut climat il faut
passer par un appel d'offres de façon à
ce qu'ils aient une concurrence en
dessous qu cima vous avez un pari
garanties sur 15 ans c'est à dire que
n'importe quel entrepreneur le plus
jeune possible qui vraiment ne gagnais
de l'argent pour faire de l'éolien peut
pas se lancer dans autre chose en cette
garantie
qu'est-ce qu'ils font des couples et
part en morceaux et ont redonné le
chiffre sur 1400 partent actuellement en
france
nos experts et ce sont des eaux et
autres personnalités ont estimé qu'ils
en avaient peut-être plus de 400 qui
fondait à cette règle coût de
l'opération pour la france sur 15 ans
3,5 milliards d'euros
c'est ça l'éolien c'est une somme
actuellement d'anomalies économique
écologique
quelle heure je parle pas au point de
vue environnemental et sociétal
pourquoi 1627 sens associations alors
pedro soler n'y en a pratiquement pas
c'est qu'on veut imposer à des français
qui n'en veulent pas des machines de 200
mètres de haut ont diaries sait même pas
que c'est à 500 mètres d'une puissance
de protection j'annonce à un évêque en
effet des distances à 100 m c'est à 300
est en réalité m'étais l'éolienne de 700
mètres en face d'une maison à vous
prenez un millefeuille à 15
des signaux et viennent vous la mettez à
oops moi et c'est ce que vous allez
avoir qu'il a tourné pendant 20 ans en
face de chez vous et qui va bouger les
alors histoire de la machine à laver je
n'accepte pas on a des gens malades sont
reconnus c'est dans mon entier et aux
liens créés dès 8 ans et ces gens là
n'en peut plus antonio duarte parce que
lucile schmitt malheureusement on a des
problèmes de liaison je peux pas vous
donner la parole mais évidemment je vous
laisse répondre antonio duarte
alors pour vous répondre non il ya
beaucoup de contre-vérités
malheureusement et je crois qu'il faut
un débat basé sur les chiffres qui sont
publiés par des instituts indépendants
comme l'ademe il ya des études tout à
fait sérieuses qui existent et
indépendantes indépendant du
gouvernement
l'éolien terrestre le coup avait été
divisé par deux en vingt ans l'éolien
maritime locaux étaient divisés par
trois en vingt ans également il est
passé de 130 euros le mégawatt à 44
euros pour le parc qui va être inauguré
à dunkerque
donc certes les premières énergies
renouvelables étaient subventionnés mais
comme l'est également le nucléaire est
ce que le p r de flamanville n'est pas
subventionner le budget dérape et par
deux l'état dû faire un chèque à edf
donc il est beaucoup plus lourdement
subventionnée que toutes les énergies
renouvelables en france
donc là dessus on ne peut pas laisser
dire des contrevérités à nos
téléspectateurs et aujourd'hui le coût
des énergies renouvelables baisse de 5%
par an alors que celui de l'énergie
nucléaire et moi je suis pas anti
nucléaires primaires comme certains
écologistes je crois qu'on a besoin
d'énergie nucléaire
il faut l'améliorer on peut pas réduire
complètement le parc nucléaire sur le
sujet le coût psychologique dans parlait
aussi monsieur aujourd'hui je crois que
bien sûr vous avez des riverains qui
peuvent être qu'ils peuvent être
gêné visuellement mais à partir du
moment où les habitations sont très
éloignées aujourd'hui la réalité c'est
que ça rapporte des revenus
complémentaires aux agriculteurs qui en
ont besoin
ça rapporte des revenus complémentaires
à des gens qui ont des terres qui ne
sont pas aujourd'hui exploités c'est
bien que la part des agriculteurs en
france a diminué drastiquement vous avez
des terres qui sont à l'abandon et je
vais pas citer des départements doit
dans la france profonde mais qui
aujourd'hui vous avez des terres qui
sont abandonnés on a un grand acteur
mais quand même aujourd'hui sur la loi
climat qui va dans le sens du zéro
artificialisation des sols c'est bien
parce que justement on a un peu une
problématique d'artificialisation les
cantons mais d'aider des éoliennes
on participe alors à ce secteur ça
consomme beaucoup moins que les berck
précieux dirige je crois je crois que
d'autres énergies
mais le sujet est la question qui est
posée ce soir c'est bien est-ce que
l'éolien en gros est la solution à tous
enfin je sais ce que j'ai aujourd'hui on
sait pas la solution à tous voilà donc
donné d'accord sur ce point donc c'est
la réponse qu'on doit aborder riz terre
d'eysines arrive dans ce cadre à porter
et vous l'avez remarqué je n'ai pas dit
il il faut tout arrêter c'est pas 2
c'est pas bien il faut faire une croix
dessus
ce que je dis c'est qu'on est dans le
hasard deux voix et que je considère que
sur un sujet comme celui là on a la
responsabilité
on doit avoir la responsabilité
collective et politique mais aussi la
société et des acteurs de ces secteurs
de rassurer l'auteur vous parliez donc
de la montée donc on a pu ressentir dans
les territoires ça me rappelle donc un
sujet un autre sujet d'actualité sur
lesquels j'ai pu venir donc dans votre
émission c'est la 5g c'est exactement le
même sujet et sur la scène j'ai la
réponse qu'on a pu apporter et que j'ai
porté donc tout dans un texte est là de
faire un texte sur l'impact
environnemental du numérique en général
parce que si on ne rassure pas les gens
par et d'ailleurs si on ne prend pas
conscience qui a un certain nombre de
sujets sur lesquels il faut être
vigilant il faut être prudent et qu'il
faut donc prendre en compte et bien
on risque de faire les mêmes erreurs et
d'avoir quelque chose qui se retournera
contre l'éolien et se dire finalement
une fin de non-recevoir vous ne pas
foncer tête baissée ce sera le mot de la
fin désolé c'est la fin de ce débat et
pardonnez-moi lucile schmid met la
liaison n'a pas été retrouvée merci
infiniment tout cas à tous les quatre
d'abord parce que vous mais ce débat fin
de cette émission se retrouvent demain à
18 heures et à 22 heures 30 demain
également 7h30 bonjour chez vous au
rayonnement de chimie recevra alexis
corbière député la france en soumises de
seine saint denis
excellente soirée
[Musique]